first yeah my business Louis never shall
forget it we met I had an eye you know
and that must have been love at first
sight
this is Charles Lala Evan all right here
we go
he and his wife Louise lived in this
house in Starkville Mississippi we were
married 59 years and 11 months and we
were one months at 60 years we almost
make fifteen actually died while I
created a unique tribute to her I
decided I do this in memory of her it
would call this Lala and Louise's play
it is personal memorial to Louise made
up of thousands of photos this is it
this is it everywhere we went we took
pictures you know you still they never
make a good when you bend over here
that'll make a little bit hold it hold
it hold it click we had talked about it
before she passed it one day we want to
be able museums put these pictures in we
didn't get a chance to do that but the
idea never left my mind in fact I'm
going to do it anyway
and this was 1968 we were going dancing
somewhere back in those days dancing was
a big thing when I first met my wife she
couldn't dance and she just got tired of
that she said you won't teach me how to
do that and after I told her we were
such a smooth couple you know we didn't
we didn't miss a beat man this is my 33
collection bow tops look at that the PO
tops me Ohio players 45 is Louisa oh man
yeah
or did we assume yes we did this right
here our last dance
I've never forget it it was in July and
I took her then the round dipped it for
the last time brought it back up put one
of them over you know the following
Friday is when she had a massive heart
attack and she wasn't refunded you know
all of a sudden she looked up at me and
said I love you and that was it
okay change another god we had such a
beautiful life I got so much to remember
and I'm just living a beautiful memory